when i was a child my brother would tell
me a bedtime story
about the man who murdered our father
hey everybody it's charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones season 8
episode 2 video so everybody grab your
valerian swords or dragonglass weapons
here we go
i'm doing game of thrones videos all
season long be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're new to the channel
and we're also doing a new round of that
hbo now giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video
careful for spoilers from episode 2
obviously we do top 10 wtf and easter
eggs from the books
starting with number 15 the trial of
jaime lannister a nice
mirror for tyrion's trial during season
4 and
cersei having to take the walk of shame
all of the lannister children now have
been held to task for their past
misdeeds
tyrion's really the only one of them who
was on trial for a crime that he did not
commit although he had plenty of past
misdeeds that he was not being tried for
there were all kinds of references from
daenerys to him becoming the kingslayer
you killed my father apparently viserys
told her a lot of stories about jaime
when she was young you promised me an
army all i see before me is one man with
one hand
everybody seems like they're trying to
set jaime off but he takes it really
calmly until bran gave him that record
drop moment just like he gave
littlefinger during season seven
chaos is a ladder in jaime's case it was
the quote that he gave him before he
pushed him out the window the things i
do for love
they call out the facts several times
during the episode that jaime has been
on the opposite side or enemies with
pretty much everybody in this room like
we here all at one point
wanted to kill the starks now we're here
defending it when they're sitting around
the hearth at the end of the episode
think about how pissed tywin lannister
would be if you were alive to see them
do this which i think is also a nice
name drop from tyrion
reminding you about brawn's secret
mission to assassinate them with the
crossbow he used to kill tywin during
season 4.
important detail too according to jaime
the golden company troops that cersei
has give or take
20 000 minus the ones that euron has
already killed she'll have enough people
to defeat anyone who survives the battle
with the white walkers during episode 3
next week
or at least jaime thinks so unless
there's some other big twist which i
talk about towards the end of this video
when i start talking about the white
walkers
i think there's going to be a big twist
with the night king and i don't think
he's going to do what you expect him to
do like bran was trying to concoct this
plan to lure him out into the open
there's a really important reason why i
don't think that's going to work i love
that jaime refused to apologize for
killing the mad king i'd do it again in
a second i was protecting my family my
house
he refuses to apologize to sansa for
taking in ned stark i was acting under
orders it was time of war i did what i
needed to do
but later in the episode he opens his
conversation with bran
by apologizing for pushing him out the
window 14 though was just setting up the
brienne jamie arc during the season they
have one of the most compelling
relationships on the show i know there's
all this torment stuff and they're using
for comedy in the background
the big woman's still here but really i
think it's all about brienne and jamie's
relationship so i'll talk about what
that is because it's not quite the same
thing as gendry and arya's relationship
or jon snow and daenerys's relationship
i think the show has just done a lot
more work establishing their
relationship than say like jon snow and
daenerys relationship which they kind of
sped
through season seven like they meet and
then a couple episodes later they're
deeply in love
there were a lot of call backs during
brienne's testimony all the way back to
season three he protected me at the cost
of his hand
that was locke's group during season
three and brienne also very aptly
puts that the only reason why sansa is
alive because of an oath that jamie
swore to catelyn stark to help
find her children and bring them home
which is why he gave brienne oathkeeper
in her armor and set her off on her way
the way sansa explained it during the
episode though is that she trusts
brienne and brienne trust jaime it's not
that sansa
trusts jaime she's just willing to give
him the benefit of the doubt based on
brienne's testimony and because of the
cersei twist almost none of them are
listening to tyrion so he's kind of on
the outs for most of the episode
number 13 jaime and bran's reunion in
the godswood
so this is sort of bran telling jaime
that he only could become the man he is
today if he had pushed bran out the
window
if he had not he would still be the
golden trash bag character that he was
at the beginning of season one
it doesn't absolve jamie of any of his
guilt and he has this really funny
reaction to bran when bran
explains how he's not bran stark anymore
i'm kind of the three-eyed raven it's
the same quizzical look that sansa had
on her face when bran told the same
thing to her
i don't know what that means three-eyed
raven what's that even though bran has
green sight and he probably has an idea
for what jamie's role is specifically he
doesn't come right out and tell him and
i love the way they leave their
conversation too
is that why should you worry about
whether or not i'm going to tell anyone
the truth about what you did to me
because we all might die tomorrow so
what would it matter after that
so you almost get a version of that same
extreme jamie reaction
face that you got at the end of episode
1 when he first noticed bran like oh my
god
but number 12 jaime and tyrion's reunion
they have a funny moment just remarking
about how
things have changed so much since the
pilot episode remember the last time we
were here
my golden days are behind me tyrion says
his whoring days are behind him and they
have that funny moment where the stark
soldiers on the balcony just spit
down at them but turns out they also
kind of hate daenerys too so tyrion
tries to reassure jaime like things
aren't quite so bad
they sort of reflect on jaime's
relationship with cersei and
tyrion actually quotes himself from
earlier on the show
so when he talks about the way that he
wants to die when i'm 80 years old in my
bed so on and so forth
that was actually a line of dialogue
from way back i think it was either
season one or season two when he was
talking to the crow hills clans of the
vale when he was with braun they got
captured he was trying to talk the storm
crows into taking him back to tywin for
a really big reward
the weird thing about tyrion in the
episode too is that there were a couple
different conversations that he had
where he talked about his own death as
if he's prophesying his own death before
the end of the series
so just watch out for him any character
that talks about their own death that
much is probably going to wind up dying
at some point
number 11 was jaime and brienne's
reunion in the yard they have a
conversation about pod which seems kind
of funny
but really it's a metaphor for what's
going on with jaime during this season
so jamie says he's come a long way but
brienne says he's still got a lot to
learn just saying that you know even
though jamie is doing the right thing
now trying to be honorable he still has
a long way to go before he completely
redeems himself
brienne stops him short as they're
talking about battle planning why aren't
you insulting me and it's sort of them
acknowledging the air between them where
they left things last time where
they know that they care about each
other but because neither one of them is
completely prepared to directly address
the way they feel about each other she
just kind of pushes them away
and it gets even more tense towards the
end of the episode but i do feel like
the two of them
later in the episode probably had one of
the best scenes in the entire episode
number 10 was daenerys vs sansa so this
actually lets you know about what's
going to be happening
after the big battle of winterfell like
what happens when we defeat the night
king there's still going to be a lot of
problems to solve
they're both wearing their new outfits
sansa has her new leather armor on
daenerys has the new furline dress they
make remarks about families being very
complicated
obvious setup for the r plus l equals j
infobomb that john is getting ready to
drop on her
the fact that it's just going to
complicate both of their families stark
and targaryen
they make a joke about jon snow being
short because she was talking about
caldrogo who was the man that you loved
before
john she talks about someone who was
taller that was khal drogo that she was
referring to
but the real tension between the two of
those characters is all about what
happens to the north after they win the
battle defeat cersei and put daenerys on
the iron throne
sansa wants continued independence for
the north after the battle daenerys
clearly isn't ready to offer that to her
so they're gonna have to circle back
around to that after the big battle to
address it before the finale
the reason they're cut short though is
actually great number nine theon
in sansa's reunion this is actually one
of the more touching reunions in the
episode it reminds you of the beginning
of season six when they first escaped
winterfell together so there were
actually a couple really good
sansa theon scenes during the episode
she seems like she cares about him a lot
the whole reason he came back though is
obviously to atone for what he did he
even references it later when bran
explains his plan for bringing the nike
out in the open and the godswood
let me defend you with the ironborn so
it's sort of him atoning
for sacking winterfell during season two
but like i said i think there's gonna be
a big twist with bran's special plan in
the night king i don't think it's gonna
work so i don't think things are gonna
go down the way they think they will
number eight though
jon snow's reunion with ed and tormund
so this is actually just a funny moment
where he sees ed and the music swells up
but tormund almost tackles him out of
frame before he can hug
ed tormund was like a master blocker
this episode like he shows up just to
make things awkward with brienne and
jamie later in the episode he stops jon
snow from hugging ed
tormund is a master at stepping in
between people
the whole point of this scene though was
just to catch everyone up to speed about
what happened at the last hearth
r.i.p little lord umber and they
basically say that anyone who hasn't
already made it to winterfell
like the glovers over in deepwood mod
they're already part of the army of the
dead
so i think that's a way to say that by
the time the white walkers have shown up
at the end of the episode
walk into frame they've already hit deep
wood mod so all the glovers are
somewhere walking around with the other
whites in the background
but number seven the big battle planning
scene so this is montage jon snow giving
voiceover and inspirational battle
planning speech while they all show off
the defenses around winterfell
he explains that they only need to kill
the night king to stop the entire army
of the dead in the other white walkers
so that's when bran launches into his
big explainer
the really cool extra new detail we get
i don't know if this is a book thing
that george r martin helped them with or
if this is just the showrunner sort of
coming up with this on the fly
is that they say that the three-eyed
raven is one of many
in a line of three-eyed ravens that the
night king has been trying to kill
up to this point so the main target as
we all suspected earlier this season
is bran himself the actor that plays the
night king before the season started did
a big interview where he says oh
i have a target during the season the
night king is coming for someone
you'll learn what it is but number six
bran explains his plan for luring him
out into the open now bran seems like
he's assuming that the night king is
going to come to winterfell
but i actually don't think that he's
going to show up because what happens at
the end of the episode when the white
walkers walk into frame on their horses
you don't see the night king anywhere
and you don't hear the dragon
screeching or flying in the background
so for all we know the night king has
turned around and gone down to king's
landing to try and start creating whites
down there
so that they have to fight a war on two
fronts instead of just this battle of
winterfell
but bran's plan is to just wait for him
in the godswood and use himself as bait
so that's you know when theon jumps in
and says we'll protect you but like i
said i don't think that it's gonna go
down the way they expect it to
brandon samwell's explanation for why
the night king wants to kill him is a
little more eloquent but it actually
does line up with most people's fan
theories just that the night king wants
to bring
winter to the entire world a
never-ending winter that's why they call
it the long night
he wants to end man as a species and
bran says the reason why he wants to
kill him because
he's a living memory of everything
that's happened in the world so you kill
him you kill memories of that
then samuel launches into a much more
eloquent explainer for it all which may
be
set up for that lord of the rings style
twist that everyone was joking about
last season
what if samwell is the one to write the
book about what just happened and he
calls it a song of ice and fire
samwell says that's what death is
forgetting being forgotten in the way
that you do not forget is that you write
stories down so hopefully they won't be
quite so on the nose about it a la lord
of the rings but let me know in the
comments if you actually think that
that's gonna happen
based on what samwell is saying in this
moment there are a couple really great
smaller scenes with a lot of the
characters having
moments together like you have the
night's watch brothers standing on the
battlements like they stood on the wall
during season one
samwell talking to ed and jon snow them
sort of poking fun at sam
well samwell slayer of white walkers
lover of ladies we're really screwed now
if this is what it's come to
they try to give all the main characters
moments like this like you have the
sergiora moment with a little bear where
she tells him i wish you good fortune in
the words to come and he's like okay
fine because she doesn't want to hide
down in the crips with everyone else
so we did finally get a sir jorah little
bear scene but that's probably going to
be the extent of it i don't expect them
to get a whole lot of time together
number five was everyone around the
hearth even though they tried to play it
really comedically there were a couple
really great moments it went a little
over the top with tormund
explaining himself like do you know how
i got the name tormund giantsbane
killed a giant when i was 10 climbed in
bed with his wife and the giantess
thought i was her child
suckled me in her teeth for three months
that's why i got so strong
giant's milk and it just gulps a whole
bunch of it down from his horn there
the funniest thing about this scene
though is actually brienne's horrified
reaction you just see her speechless
there just trying to take it all in oh
my god what did i just hear
and during all those moments where he
was trying to proposition brienne you
could actually see
her in frame with jamie just out of
focus it was just sort of their way of
addressing the funny love triangle
that's been happening
for the past couple of seasons but like
i said i think this is all about
jaime and brienne they've been setting
that up ever since season three ever
since he explained
why he became the king slayer number
four was arya's second reunion with the
hound which was a little more personal
but they also got the reunion with beric
who she hasn't seen since season three
i love the way she checked him too what
are you doing here you've never fought
from anyone but yourself
and then he remarks i fought for you
didn't i which is a way to show you that
they both come a long way
he's actually being more honorable being
a good person she's kind of gone in the
opposite direction even though she is
fairly well adjusted she is a stone cold
killer at this point
they drop a really big red wedding
reference when barrick walks up and the
town gets really pissed off oh we might
as well be at a bloody
wedding which at the end of season three
they walked up at the twins
right after the red wedding had gone
down arya lets us know that barrick
isn't on her list anymore i think that
happened during season six when the wait
was questioning him it was just a really
way of acknowledging how arya cared
about
the hound at that point number three
though was aryan gendry finally doing
the deed as
awkward as possible as you would expect
from a couple people like that arya's
first time i won't want to die without
experiencing this so let's just get it
on get it over with i'm not the red
woman take your own damn pants off
she seems a little surprised when he
tells her about his true origin i'm
robert baratheon's bastard but i don't
think that mattered to her before so i
don't think that it really changes
anything about the way she feels about
gendry
the other really interesting thing too
about their scene is that when she's
taking her clothes off gendry notices
all of her scars from her training is
the same kind of look that daenerys gave
jon snow when she saw all of his scars
during season 7 episode 6 like
wow what happened there there's clearly
a story behind all those scars
number two though obviously was jamie
knighting brienne
if you didn't recognize they were
actually playing the same soundtrack
from when he gave her oath keeper even
though it sounded like an oath keeper
theme song
the name of the song is actually called
kingslayer so it started out as a jaime
lannister theme then once they got to
season four their relationship had
blossomed a little bit more
it turned into a theme for both of them
in that oath keeper moment so i think of
the song as more of an oath keeper theme
which makes sense
now that he's knighting here rise a
knight of the seven kingdoms
the really interesting book easter egg
there is that a night of the seven
kingdoms is a reference to the book
called a night of the seven kingdoms
which covers the adventures of dunkin
egg that george r martin wrote within
the world of a song of ice and fire
brienne of tarth is actually related
to sir duncan the tall if you couldn't
tell what that podrick song was too big
surprise twist pod is apparently a
really amazing singer
maybe the other surprise twist is that
that's what he did to the girls in the
whorehouse so many seasons ago like what
did he do to those girls that make them
love him so much
but the name of the song that he's
singing is called jenny's song and it's
fabled that the song was always
requested
from jenny by the ghost of the high
heart as payment in exchange for telling
the brotherhood without banners of her
prophetic dreams
so it's kind of a book easter egg for
something that they didn't really do
on the tv show but obviously the song
itself was just really nice the way they
used it during the episode
i love the transition to the next big
jon snow daenerys scene too as the song
is being sung you have this big montage
you see all the different characters and
groups all around the castle
you see daenerys enter the crips as jon
snow is standing at lyanna stark's
statue and she remarks about rhaegar
targaryen oh he did all these terrible
things to leona stark
they said that he was a great singer
obviously referencing the jenny of
oldstone song
that compels jon snow to tell her the
truth and she doesn't believe it almost
as much as jon snow didn't believe it he
was a little
quicker to believe what samuel was
telling him oh your best friend
and your brother told you something and
you're gonna believe it outright it's
true i know it's true
the way they're spinning daenerys
reaction is that she's thinking more of
it from a succession standpoint oh you
have a claim to the iron throne now
you're competing with me for the thing
that i've wanted this whole time even
though i think that they're overblowing
that point a little bit
they're probably gonna use it as a point
of drama between the two of them for the
rest of the season at least until the
last couple of episodes
everything goes wrong for everyone all
at the same time as things just start
spinning out of control as the white
walkers arrive
the horn sounds the white walkers arrive
but like i said i think the twist that
we're not expecting here is that the
night king won't even be at this battle
it'll just be his white walker generals
in the army of the dead
and the night king will try to beeline
down for king's landing
so prepare yourself next week will be
their helms deep episode as they're
calling it lord of the rings style just
an episode where it's nothing but this
giant battle going on the biggest battle
in tv history so it is going to be epic
the episode's gonna be way longer than
episodes one and two so i might have to
do like a top 20 wtf video
but leave all your questions in the
comments below i'll do an episode three
trailer video tomorrow i'll name a
giveaway winner when i post that in a q
a video on tuesday just like i did last
week
but while you wait for everything click
here for my aria and gendry season 8
video
and click here for my game of thrones
season 8 episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you